[Music]  tonight we're taking game night up a  notch oh boy someone in this room is  going to be taken and it's gonna be up  to you to find them it's a murder  mystery party whoever finds the victim  wins the grand prize you're not gonna  know what's real and what's fake wait a  sec you can't just come in here and  break the door guys make sure you get a  piece of this cheese it's just suck okay  Roger that you drive safe I've always  enjoyed the camaraderie of good friends  competing in games of chance and skill  [Music]  Jerry fella  this games like Ryan you go Chris I'm  scared  [Music]  it's no joke people are in real danger  [Music]  Oh take a little path so much worse  stop meet me I have kids at home not  with an ass like that you don't oh thank  you oh no he died his instructions on  how to remove the bullets didn't have  rubbing alcohol so I got you this lovely  sharp good idea way to pivot and then a  squeaky toy for the pain  [Music]  [Music]